hi in this video we'll talk about the
promoter elements so RNA polymerase
promoters are specialized DNA sequence
which are located near the transcription
start site and whose sole goal is to
serve as a platform such that the
transcription machinery and assemble on
there and transcription can begin so
here is a fragment of a DNA where you
can see the area marked in green is a
promoter element the promoter element is
a specialized sequence about its
sequence feature we would look later but
right now this promoter element is a
platform where the transcriptional
initiation machinery the general
transcription factors and the RNA
polymerase would bind and as a result
transcription would start so promoter
elements as we discussed could be
upstream to the transcription start site
or it could be downstream to the
transcription start site and there are
both their variances one of the most
common promoter element is located 24 to
my 24 to 30 base pairs upstream the
minus sign indicates which is upstream
from the transcription start site and
this promote this promoter element is
known as Tara box just few base upstream
to Tara box there is another element
known as BRE element so this is another
promoter element which is present in the
upstream now we look at at the Tara box
the tf2d
which he has the Tara box binding
protein which is a general transcription
factor binds and allows the whole
transcription initiation machinery to be
associated near the promoter and near
the transcription start site now the
transcription can start we can also talk
about a little bit about the downstream
promoter elements such as dpe which are
mostly present in positive 28 to 34
nucleotides which is downstream towards
from the transcript
start site now how to understand that a
promoter is strong or weak we know that
this if this is a promoter region and
this is a gene body region our
transcriptional machinery assembled in
the promoter region and near the
transcription start site right so we can
have an in vivo or in vitro reporter
assay so what is a reporter acid let's
say you amplify the sequence of the
promoter and you know the transcription
machinery assembles with that then you
put a reporter element which you can
detect for example in this particular
case we have put a GFP trans gene
underneath this promoter and if the
promoter is getting activated so GFP
would be transcribed and translated and
as a result we can detect the
fluorescence the fluorescence level was
tell us that the promoter is active or
not active now let's say there are two
promoters promoter and promoter B
promoter a gives rise to quite a lot of
GFP mRNA and produced lot of GFP whereas
promoter B give rise to less amount of
mRNA and give rise to less amount of GFP
protein as well so both the fluorescence
signal could be detected using specific
fluorescence detector and that would
tell us the fluorescence intensity would
tell us the fluorescence how much strong
one promoter is or how efficient the
promoter is in terms of transcription
and this is called in vivo in vivo in
vitro reporter asses now there is a
problem that what we talked about so far
inside a cell the promoter is not only a
single strand of DNA this specific
sequence is actually wrapped around the
histones forming nucleosomes and you
have to understand a
jean is also informative a nucleosome so
just upstream to the start site the RNA
polymerase need to bind and need to move
all across the gene body so thinking
about the chromatin conformation is also
important to understand the promoters so
the promoter elements could be
classified on basis of several
parameters such as initiation pattern
sequence composition motifs chromosome
configuration and gene functions and
based on these classifications so what
we can see the crow molt from the
promoter elements could be
differentiated as promoters of adult and
differentiated tissues such as the
promoters which are found in neuron skin
cells or a fiberglass there are
promoters of housekeeping gene that
means the promoters which are found in
the housekeeping genes such as acting
also there are promoters of
developmentally related transcription
factors such as Sox - promoter which
really are important for stem cell
maturation or stems or maintaining the
stem cell state we would learn about all
these and what are the features of these
promoters in a bit so the tissues which
are adult or terminal terminally
differentiating their promoters has
regularly or scattered placed
nucleosomes whereas the housekeeping and
the developmental gene promoters have
mostly regularly spaced nucleosomes so
in terms of nucleosome their
organization is very different now let's
talk about the transcription start site
the transcription start sequence site or
the frequency of the transcription start
events are very sharp in case of a
terminally differentiated gene promoter
whereas it is more broad in terms of
housekeeping gene promoters and
relatively sharper than the housekeeping
in case of the developmentally important
genes now in terms of activator ii and
inhibitory marks mostly the terminally
differentiated gene promoters and the
housekeeping gene promoter has activated
mark whereas the
mentally related gene promoters which
are important for stem-cell maintenance
and etc they have both the type of marx
activator II as well as inhibitory and
they're staying in a poised state such
that they could be either differentiated
anytime or they could undergo a self
renewal processes at the same time so
till now we can understand that
information about the promoter and how
the promoter is oriented in a
three-dimensional space of what type of
histone is associated with that promoter
sequence means a lot for in terms of
gene regulation and cells performance
right but not only the sequence itself
or what is binding to the sequence there
are other sequence nearby to the
promoter such as enhancer sequence which
can influence that promoters activity a
promoter might be very weak but if I
enhancer is nearby it would enhance the
transcriptional activity from the
promoter itself or some of the cases
there are repressor elements which would
repress the transcription from that
promoter so it all is influenced by
several sis regulatory element want to
know more about uses and transfer
emulator element a new video would be
coming so stay tuned if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you